rewrite each fraction with a denominator
of ten so we have two fractions three
fifths and seven halves and we want to
take their denominators of five and two
and change them to be a common
denominator of 10 so let's start with
three-fifths and we can look at this
visually here we can use this rectangle
to represent a whole one whole and to
show three fifths of that whole we're
going to need to divide it into fifths
or five equal pieces
so let's do that we try to make these as
equal as possible and so we have three
pieces and then finally there we go so
these should represent five equal pieces
or fifths and to show three fifths we
need to shade three of those five pieces
so one two three of those five pieces
should be shaded in to show three-fifths
but we've decided we don't want fifths
any more now we want tenths we want a
new denominator of ten so to change this
fraction over here to change this to be
tenths we need to split each of these
fifths in half we need to double the
amount of pieces so we can do that here
and now instead of fifths or five equal
sized pieces we have tenths we have one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten so we found a way to have tents
without changing the amount that's
represented the same amount is still
shaded but now we have tenths so our
denominator doubled we multiplied it by
two we have twice as many pieces but
look at what happened to our numerator
instead of three pieces now we have one
two three four five six pieces
it also doubled it also was multiplied
by two
- because if we double all of the pieces
well then the shaded ones will also
double each of those pieces also split
in two so now there's twice as many
shaded pieces so three fifths can be
re-written as six tenths three fifths is
equal to six tenths and again we didn't
change the fraction we didn't change how
much was shaded three fifths and six
tenths represented the same amount we
just changed the denominator and wrote
it a different way so three fifths can
be re-written in tenths as six tenths
and now for seven halves we again we
want a denominator of ten so we could
draw it out or we could try to use this
pattern we just noticed up here to
figure out how to make halves turn into
tenths to get from fifths two tenths we
had to double or multiply by 2 to get
from halves to tents we'd have to
multiply each of our pieces times five
times five each of our halves would be
split into five pieces so we'd multiply
two times 5 to get tenths and like the
pattern showed us up here if the
denominator is multiplied by a number we
multiply the numerator by the same
number because those shaded pieces would
also be split five times so we'd
multiply our seven times five also these
should match the numerator and
denominator multiplied by the same
number and seven times five is
thirty-five
so thirty-five tenths is equal to seven
halves so to change these two fractions
to have a common denominator of 10
three-fifths will become six tenths and
seven halves will become 35 tenths